dreams without goals are just dreams and
they ultimately fuel disappointment
goals on the road to achievement cannot
be achieved without discipline and
consistency I pray that you all put your
shoes way under the bed that night so
that you got to get on your knees in the
morning get something you never had you
have to do something you never did les
Browns a motivational speaker you made
an analogy about this he says imagine
you're on your deathbed and standing
around your deathbed are the ghosts
representing your unfulfilled potential
the ghosts of the ideas you never acted
on the ghosts of the talents you didn't
use and they're standing around your bed
angry disappointed and upset they say we
came to you because you could have
brought us to life they say and now we
have to go to the grave together so I
ask you today how many ghosts are going
to be around your bed when your time
comes you just watched two amazing clips
from Denzel Washington take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]